we are live we're live again guys we are
live is it we are in Burbank California
red Beemer alive yeah
hey joining us a sports man everybody
welcome to another punch-drunk sports re
is in his apartment
I like how you framed yourself with like
a brick background like even your
apartment looks like a stand-up comedy
club oh yeah there you go that's fine
and in Johnny's years well Aaron's here
Aaron how are you I am good
despite Johnny's team being mine all
weekend got in that ass baby and then
the Yankees Yankees the Lakers getting
the bra it's gross yeah but here's why
okay first I was really sad about it and
really distressed but then it hit me
yeah that they are still not capable of
beating Houston or Golden State
absolutely I'm not gonna be a 1 seed so
they're gonna have to get to both of
them
that's enough fever think it seed or the
3 seed or the 4 seed they're gonna have
to get to both those people that's not
the show so they're not gonna start
winning championships again all right I
think they're on a two-year plan I think
because they just signed a bunch of guys
to have one they can get rid of in one
year and then the next season they're
supposed to be ready for two more years
well that's a Magic Johnson bet it's a
two-year plan don't get your hopes up
that it's a two-year plan and he said
that before they got LeBron and before a
before the state got boogie cousins and
before they got Rondo and the Golden
State or Houston there I mean I know
LeBron is a one-man playoff game yeah
you know but like I think there's hope
here I think they're still gonna be they
be the new Clippers they're not gonna
give us a second round for like three
straight years and then be like oh [ __ ]
now we have no traveler like it didn't
Leonard make it clear that he's gonna
sign with the Lakers though no
I would argue with Stephen a Smith
literally said huh well and I mean
that's the big fear is that that quite
Leonard goes there I think they thought
that they might have got had a chance of
getting boogie cousins and then he
cousins went to Golden State and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] man you see dude
[ __ ] the NBA next year nice thinking so
hurry I'm not gonna watch the NBA until
the Late Late Late Late playoffs now who
are you thinking I should get yeah well
if he doesn't come back at all it's
still the same Golden State team that
was untouchable
I thought seth Curry was gonna go down
there for a while you know a bookie
cousins he said boogie cousin said that
nobody offered him a contract he had to
call Golden State to get on their team
nobody I mean he was gonna he doesn't
work hard and now he's coming off the
Achilles tear that you have to be
extremely unlace II to rehab from but
it's also a free agency just started you
know his phone was gonna ring if it had
it in the first two days it's awfully
strange here but the real problem with
that Ari isn't and you're in New York
the real problem with LeBron coming in
Lakers isn't win or if they're gonna win
a [ __ ] championship which would be a
nightmare what the problem is this is
all you ever have heard about every
[ __ ] moment every corner that you go
to all you hear about is LeBron now have
you last night at friends and family you
couldn't get to a circle of conversation
that wasn't [ __ ] LeBron you can't
watch the news you can't watch
SportsCenter you can't watch anything uh
you know what where he lives they're
doing tours of his house forever that's
all you hear about where is this kid
gonna go to school you
what are the piece is going to be not
finally we had about of maybe a year and
a half two year window where you just
weren't bombarded with Laker talk as a
clipper fan or just an NBA fan you get
sick of hearing about the goddamn Lakers
here and now it's just come man bye
Felicia
well do it and season tickets jump by
two thousand dollars on average you you
won't be able to go to a game you won't
be able to go to a gank god exactly
exactly and I heard all the comedy shows
are gonna be awesome on all this nights
that oh they're gonna be super great
every time LeBron is playing basketball
above my head while I'm trying to do my
act at some sports bar Oh gross gross
do you read the news about the one-year
contracts that were going around you
know with Pope Steve it's in McGee Rondo
you know all those guys at issue yeah
even as bookies as a one-year deal of
things yet cousins yeah well Brian you
had a really insightful comment about
LeBron James signing it is your call on
Twitter I believe oh yeah yeah I mean it
is a numbers game so it doesn't matter
who signs who it's the only thing that
matters his but it is a numbers game 154
million is that right 154 that's a good
deal if you think about it they've
already made that money they probably
have already made that money it really
is like he's like he's like what stage
Jeremy Lin Jeremy Lin where it's like
he's worth more than his talent yeah
wait right ban who just answered that me
it was Johnny are you what a [ __ ] his
pants these do you know you're Asians
yeah so I'm just you know it is the
elephant in the room the [ __ ] goddamn
LeBron ting elephants yeah yeah
and you're just like [ __ ] man it's the
last thing you wanted and it happens so
quick I guess I'm glad it happened quick
it's like ripping a band-aid off it's if
it's gonna happen let's get it over with
yeah instead of me having to go where's
LeBron going stinks from now until I
handled it way better than he did two
times ago but dude the people that the
the the people that are coming out of
the woodwork now the the Chris burns of
the world the all these Laker fans that
haven't had a chance to talk [ __ ] now oh
man are they yappin are they yappin
they're already yeah immediately because
they never stop thinking about James
just before the five years where they
were horrible those fans are all like
yeah we're right about turning around
win a championship or is good job fix
know Sargon know they do the other thing
they do the other thing where they go
how many rings do you got how many was
like yeah you had some in like the 80s
in like 90s but losing a [ __ ]
confidence in their team when they start
going like oh but we had finally beaten
them down to being the people like how
many rings do you have which is one
click away from them not being able to
talk [ __ ] at all you know and then they
get [ __ ] LeBron haha man that really
sucks it jerseys are gonna be everywhere
oh god it really sucks man
and there's nothing you can do about it
you just got it just gotta listen to it
source man you seem to have a thought no
I was thinking more of the Clippers I'm
just happy that Avery Bradley got to
sign on to another two-year contract you
know so that's good news for the
Clippers I mean your other you're gonna
be able to get good you're gonna be able
to get clipper tickets for [ __ ] a
goddamn song and a dance and a pack of
cigarettes you'll be able to get a
clipper tich know and I guess that's
good news
it'll be like the old days it'll be like
when I went when I moved out here and in
with Shaq and Kobe and they were
building the Staples Center the forum
wasn't even built yet you couldn't get a
goddamn lake or take it to save your
life
you got to the Clipper game early enough
you might be able to like come off the
bench and play yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
gonna be like that
again that was like free Darius Miles
days and whatnot you know who's your
team re the pills
should be the Hornets Michigan yeah the
Michigan pelicans cuz yeah actually that
state is not just full of pelicans all
over the state of Michigan isn't that
isn't it called pelicans because some
dumb wife wanted it to be some stupid or
something like I'm trying to build a
sports Empire I could do the name
because yeah yeah you can do the name I
just chose the dumbest [ __ ] shut up
right I'm I really a Charlotte Bobcats
to retake the name they also took their
entire history the entire Borden's
history so it's really the team you
should be rooting for it's in Charlotte
sorry so what so Chris Paul has some
stats with the Hornets and some stats
with the [ __ ] pelicans well no no
only the stats that were in Charlotte
are yeah there's now sure but when you
were a fan when they were in Charlotte
that's all in Charlotte again it doesn't
count towards the pelicans well that's
well I mean it's stupid yeah but that's
what they I'm impressed you're saying
then Chris Paul has not played for three
teams he's played for four
I know Chris Paul never played in
Charlotte so you didn't know oh no they
got him after that when the city no cuz
Mara Baron Davis was on that last
Charlotte team he was a point guard on
the house Charlie team and like really
David Wesley yeah and those guys were
you stunned at the that boogie that the
pelicans didn't want boogie no played
better without him and then they're like
with that without his injury too like he
every experiment didn't work Davis and
Gus's together did not work it seemed
like it should after the first year
you're like well and then he got injured
in that year too you're like alright
they're starting to get together maybe
it'll take some time it shouldn't take
any time to run the high/low it should
be real easy I mean both kind of watch
each other and all the other players
just kind of washed each other so like
his stats are fine but it
resulting in wins and then when he went
out and Mira muriatic was the [ __ ]
run-and-gun kind of guy Santa where it's
like oh these are they're better team
with Murata
so why sign cousins at all and then when
he's coming off this horrible injury
they're like nah man we don't think we
want you for free I think we'd rather
just got the calf space well you got the
ex Laker Center Julius Randle added to
the roster forward I like it I like it a
lot talking about all morning he's
washed up who cares about Rhonda I'm
interested to see how Rhonda's
personality goes with balls personality
because they both seem like the same
sort of [ __ ] [ __ ]
lost in the locker room some people
think ball might get his walking papers
do they might trade his ass I've seen
that a few places I was you know the
Bron James sabre-2 one about him
he ain't gonna be putting up with that
guy's dad he's gone this [ __ ] stops
today for sure you know because even
before they got him he was his dad was
like there ain't nothing he can teach my
son LeBron they gonna come here and
straighten him out they none let me hit
LeBron can teach my son oh girl oh I bet
there is
[ __ ] so you know and then these
items so now it's like he like LeBron's
give me like this [ __ ] that this crazy
[ __ ] stops today there's Kim Kardashian
kris kardashian of the NBA [ __ ] is it's
a rap because like you want an old
veteran like if you get a 15-year guy
even like a Patrick Ewing in his in his
and they were like well sign him to
teach you know Alonzo Mourning how to
play well sign him to teach someone else
how to play it's like especially LeBron
James oh yeah exactly
although I mean those guys those
all-time greats how often are they
really good mentors I mean Jordan was
never a mentor to anybody you know yeah
I mean he's not shaken
I don't think LeBron having a mentor of
all
Koby same with kobe he didn't wanna help
anybody out course not
I think these greats these all-time
greats they're not actually usually
pretty good at bringing lively centers
are yeah totally yeah and he was always
like an all-star till the end just like
those guys he was never like bad that
Ewing was right right right people say
like it's us LeBron never had a great
team and in Cleveland it's like no raw
they had Kevin Love Kyrie Irving and him
that was a super team and they just up
seen worse with LeBron he made those
players were see stats were great he
made the people around him play worse
well yeah Kevin Love they talk like
Kevin Love is nobody the guy's one of
the best rebounders and then in the game
in a long time and and they I mean give
me a [ __ ] break dude he's gonna go
somewhere else if they he ever gets out
of there and and watch he's gonna yeah
but he was a great he was a great player
yes right those rebounds are just I mean
nobody was that good you know who looks
like SuperDuper banged up to like
nowadays talk about like all ten players
Larry Bird I do just hobbles around like
you're like damn your body took a
pounding dude everybody's bodies are
like that though after a long NBA season
probably yeah or better like oh well how
would you how would you say Larry season
was it was pretty long that's the
coolest thing about LeBron moving to Los
Angeles we're almost guaranteed a Space
Jam too and I guess new trailers gonna
drop this summer this summer yeah
I don't know what like Kyrie Irving and
there's something he has a studio LeBron
has a studio at Warner Brothers you know
he's like a 30% owner of like who was in
Fiat not a FIFA who is in the Champions
League final there wasn't man you but
anyway he's like a 30% owner of of that
team no [ __ ]
it's got owns a soccer team in London
should buy the Lakers I'm trying to find
he probably could he's in some part of
Liverpool is that what you're saying uh
whoever was in the finals
I remember cuz I watched the finals with
my buddy and then he was they mentioned
that in the in the broadcast
sounds like he's actually making some
good money from that - it's an
investment rather than just like a lark
rere what do you have on your counter
you have three blue boxes right above
you is that yeah you're right all right
you're right you're right well there's
three boxes behind you behind your left
shoulder hit black boxes
what are you selling pot a 14-year olds
bro got nine thousand ziplock bags oh
[ __ ]
that's his uh fart mask laying knocked
up what are you a [ __ ] 16 year old
boy oh my god you got nine thousand
ziplock bags and a [ __ ] bomb gas mask
and you can unscrew that bong to put it
any kind you got a drone in a skateboard
- you [ __ ] I hate it when you buy
things on Amazon you don't realize it's
coming with like a million of them i buy
it you know those little packets you can
put in water like that you know like
Orange Crush they have these little
packets to make one crystal lighter that
crystal light yeah yeah uh so I found
out they had like they're all sugar-free
calorie-free like Orange Crush oh yeah
yeah and so I bought one and I was like
20 bucks for like before you know for
different kinds of Orange Crush that's
cool it was 400 like it came to Shu
Hmong I have so much of this [ __ ] like
like and I'm just putting it in
everything like that's great well and
they ship these giant boxes like I got a
deck of cards the other day it came in a
box it was this [ __ ] big yeah they
really don't give a [ __ ] about the other
worst is when you cardboard order
something from there they you totally
forget about and it's like you could
pick like something to be like out of
fifteen twenty dollars no like you can
it's coming from like China and like you
can pay $41 and have this in two days
which is double the price of the thing
yeah or you can pay the free Freight and
it'll show up whenever and I like three
months go by you've totally forget you
get a package like what the [ __ ] is this
oh that watch I ordered I wonder how
many things I've ordered and completely
forgot about from that probably none
taken
so what I would get is I would get
packages and then I would just like to
forget where they were and I was like I
don't feel like opening them now
and then I would just put him in the
corner my place on Sunset and then I'll
get another Packers like months later
and I put it in a pile and they just
start piling up I went Tony and Matt
Edgar try to help me clean my apartment
like what are all these Amazon boxes I'm
like I just stuff I ordered about how
long like five years I guess va said so
Christmas and we just heard opening
presents then Ari Shaffir thought Ari
Shaffir would enjoy talking about AHS
rewind errs and [ __ ] was a finger
passing on a like a vacuum sealer I was
like that's cool and then I open another
box of like oh another batteries I need
to get one of those that's my one the
other day
wait what else because I gave them both
oh yeah you gave one of his awake
already
what what else was there there's all
sorts of stuff some t-shirts just like
so much [ __ ]
things I didn't meet I mean nothing
perishable and what were you doing like
getting high and going on Amazon at
night and [ __ ] like that
I don't desire anything right now so
it's not like I'm like oh [ __ ] me to
this thank God yes books I don't
remember
re like a long time ago you had me order
something from Amazon for some reason I
don't know though I feel like was a
laptop or something but the other day
ordered something in your eye
you were the only one our friends left
prime oh that's that's right and stuff I
ordered something other day and it's
shipped to your address and I had to
like I had to like cancel it was such a
pain in the ass because it had already
shipped and then it was your sunset
address why is this my Amazon still I
still have like all these like random
addresses from people Amazon Prime baby
Ari Aaron was talking about his softball
league Terrell Owens just came by and
subbed in like [ __ ] it know what yeah
and didn't even touch a car home or did
he know and there's no fences he he hit
a couple doubles and pitched he pitched
and hit a couple doubles that's
dangerous dude pitch you get to [ __ ]
rocket fired right back at his face oh
yeah [ __ ] did you see he ran
like a four for the other day four four
six or some [ __ ] four four three still I
can't I mean speed is usually the thing
that goes on there's old guys right yeah
we [ __ ] Julio Jones hula Jones timed
it Julio just gonna hold out yeah god I
don't know gonna hold out Terrell Owens
like cuz he's like guys holding out is
not a thing trial Owens is the only one
who knew about ah I blame trial Owens
he's got a contract he's got an agent
contract me nothing
well guys he's like Julio Jones like the
I don't know eighth or ninth
highest-paid receiver coming into the
last year of a contract which is
probably and he's like I come on yeah
come on
I'm the that's what he's basically once
yeah but
like you don't want to see you know you
haven't held out doesn't want to go
somewhere else next year all this you
use of the h h o word he hasn't held out
you know i'ma get a panther fan would
like that I get you know but he hasn't
held out but I do blame Terrell Owens
you know you started hanging out with
certain people they start giving you
know yappin in your ear you know they
start influencing you Terrell Owens was
a king of old now when Mike Vick is wade
in he says the who a Jones does deserve
a bigger convent yeah let's listen to
that guy that guy's and bitten doing
nothing but making smart business
decisions his entire life I mean Hugh
even asked him yeah what are they PI
asked him because he's a foul kidding he
knows him they know each other I see
yeah what's his relationship with the
team is he kind of been disassociated
because no they've actually kind of
welcomed him back and I think I think
they might even see it you hear that
dogs barking dog barking right we start
to talk about michael vick wow that dog
is like enough change the subject
see that's what's great about things
economy even the dogs are upstairs
watching the show right now live on the
Internet
cuz why re because we're live we're live
we are live so I don't know if I blame
him but he's having his Hall of Fame
induction speech from his college
whenever he wants to Terrell Terrell
Owens isn't it rel owns so so he's not
going to the no because you've been
begging to get into the Hall of Fame and
yappin about how you deserve to be in
the Hall of Fame
if you don't I think that he has to pay
for the party I don't think he has to I
don't know I don't know which part and I
have they actually confirmed that that's
what his beef is I think I think he
thought he should have been first ballot
I think this is beef so he's
so he's being a prima donna about not
being first ballot no I'm pretty sure
that's it yeah Jesus Christ this guy I
mean I always loved him I was less of my
own son he was entertaining but I also
think he has shown the propensity to be
a locker room cancer he get frustrates
the [ __ ] out of coaches he scrambled
Jeff Garcia's brains dude I mean he
remember in San Francisco or Jeff Garcia
destroyed that guy's career Jeff Garcia
was a what think of this guy's name Jeff
Garcia is the white Rodney Peete yes
yeah they're comparably maybe Jeff
Garcia a little bit better but yeah he
played for the Panthers for writing he
played for every single NFL team I think
beautiful wife she was a smoker still
probably hot today but in her life 21
Jump Street did she was a smoke show
Holly Robinson Peete ari what's that
no no Rodney Peete is married to Holly
Robinson I think Jeff Garcia's go really
Jeff Garcia's wife is I heard he looks
like a like a yeah a plate like a
Instagram model okay I think she's to
fit in the seat she's good she's got big
teeth I know he would love that he likes
big teeth he talks about all the time
he's like I love more than like a nice
horse teeth here you go all right hey
Ari here's here's Jeff Garcia is a old
lady she's like just classic goes pretty
I agree she's like a classroom pretty
but I think she was in Playboy perhaps
this is Rodney Peete woman today today
okay looking good holding it together
it's all right she looks good today
keeping it tight look at him sure when
she was young no Holly Robinson she was
on 21 Jump Street right yeah she's also
in Howard
duck Howard the Duck Oh Jack what that
was her back in the days in the band
yeah yeah yeah she was totally she
wasn't Howard the Duck I don't remember
that I barely remember that did they
remake that know they put I spent in the
new movies oh he's been like Easter eggs
yeah that's maybe what I was thinking of
so Howard the ducking in the movie
theater when it came out and I think I
saw with my mom and she thought it was
gonna be like a kids movie and I just
remember condoms and yes it likes me to
play play bill magazine yeah those are
my Marvel comic I think oh that's where
I saw him in you guys see ready player
one yet you know how is it it's really
great it's really great and it's very
cool to see like all the old cartoon
characters from it's like Roger Rabbit
for adults kind of like okay it's bad
acid but there's a lot of things like
that in the movie that you're like I
completely forgot about that
I completely forgot I like I highly
recommend it it's just for the the nerd
80s nerd in you I still haven't seen
that um what you call it I want to see
that uh what's his [ __ ] name mr.
roberts mr. roberts mr. rogers sorry
have you seen it everybody says it's
great like a you'll see it you'll be
like man I gotta get my [ __ ] together
yeah what do you saying Jenni well not
what do you mean like like because he's
such a nice guy that you were these nice
guy but he was also like you know active
in his community and like stood up for
other people's rights and you know but
wasn't a very selfish person and in time
for that I mean yeah but you know what
did it get him death so was he married I
don't know no I think he was and I don't
quote me because I'm just you know I
don't remember where I heard this but I
think he used to did a little boys well
that's why I was gonna say I wonder if
there's any kind of skeletons in his
closet and me like I'd like you know
molesting chicks or guys I mean look at
Kevin Smith
there's a [ __ ] like murdered villages
in Vietnam that kind of [ __ ] she did I
think he's like a war hero ah oh no
she's still alive he was married when he
died okay
yeah Joanne bird how long were they
married from 52 to death in 2000 a
muscle like her I mean 51 years you tell
me that looks like what his wife would
like that is what I know but that's what
I would be like wow really I mean but
that's what she looked like when they
met he's here 50 [ __ ] two years later
she's a squirter good man when she pees
I mean good for him you know she was
probably a timepiece back in a day we're
all gonna look based on what I don't
know I mean we've all aged terribly I
know well she wasn't I'm 14 years old
look at me I'm 14 years old look at this
what's happened to me
ari what's the oldest woman that you've
been with have you been with let's play
this game in with an older older woman
like that way but I was 27 I hook up
with a 35 year old that's pretty good
okay so yeah yeah eight your difference
yeah but the weird thing is now I would
almost never hook up with a 35 year old
yeah yeah that's way too old
oh I totally would yeah 35 says me next
to makes fun of me because he was
telling me something he hooked up once
it was like I know yours and years ago
we're in a fan Toronto Glenwood kick and
he was like telling this some go and
somebody's like I was in the back he
always reminds me of this and somebody's
like how old was she and he goes 41 or
something like that but as soon as the
words out of his mouth I was he was in
the front seat it was a middle seat and
then the back he goes just from the back
you just hear our ego I read read you
say at 41 you say 41 41 yes Kareem
Matthews posted this [ __ ] video look
at this dude can you play it up the
thing yeah it's it's quite seen this he
really digs his hands in her ass
he's squeezing that tampon at her Wow so
this is like an old folks home it looks
like and it's just two old-timers
grinding on each other they gotta be in
there lady she just came and yeah he's
grinding the [ __ ] suckin beating the
tar out of her out of her hamburger Hall
I deploy you for sure that's an employer
and he's almost like kind of like hunk
Tovar like almost like an twere a rabbit
would [ __ ] no he's just like I think
that is it I think they both came during
that like that's I think there's no way
they're me to get horn your body
language after that well it gives me
hope for being in an old folks home well
apparently there all happens now yeah I
guess herpes is like crazy insane well
that's thank you
you know pharmaceuticals that's just
causes boner pills that these guys can
take now you know they're like [ __ ] yeah
I'm not gonna get hard again and I'm
bored as [ __ ]
let me get Blanche to come [ __ ] suck
my how about this one speaking of which
this is a good segue
Floyd Mayweather senior hurry Floyd
Mayweather's senior senior just 65 65
years old just yes he did I just got a
paternity suit and just got found you
are the father of a one-year-old
so congratulations Floyd Mayweather jr.
you now have a one-year-old brother
who's [ __ ] this 70 year old scumbag
he's that guy has been an [ __ ] his
entire career when he was a boxer he was
a jerk he had all these domestic dispute
things he's been arrested several times
he was a shitty [ __ ] father
that woman is [ __ ] him apparently
there was just on the screen her name is
Parisa so what woman looks at that dudes
track record and is like mmm I got to
get me some of that seven-year old dick
up and Sammy oh he has five other
children at least they said the team's
he said at least five other children so
they play as five children with seven
different women
when chosen numbers he's banging Siamese
twins
uh of course she does she has a father
she's like I'm gonna get knocked up by
[ __ ] Floyd dad what I will let me see
let me see who [ __ ] this guy yeah the
picture oh yeah she's on the screen Oh
Aaron can pull it up I have it here I
don't know man parisa harissa yeah I
think she's in love I think they must be
in love crusty he's got to be does it
has a rage I think she's older I think
she's like 30-something I think I've
read yeah she's at the point where she's
having sex with 65 year old dudes she's
I mean not in her prime that's not a
cash grab is it depends man maybe he
just got a big got some good game you
know like apparently he's got [ __ ]
well he just goes around saying uh Boyd
Mayweather that's what he says that's
his whole line right as a tub of coconut
butter just stroking it come on in lady
I mean is that I guess it's not that
gross I mean if your kid is [ __ ] a
billionaire practically and super famous
I didn't mean is it a scumbag move to
use that to get [ __ ] in your 70s oh no
okay
I mean I'm just putting that question
out there when you're I mean do you want
to be that kind of guy would you guys
want to be that kind of a man yeah oh
yeah the man who gets laid into 70s yeah
young puss yeah but now this [ __ ] does
she got her hands in his pocket he's not
being smart about his pocket his sons
pocket yeah I'm sure how does he still
have working sperm now at that age
that's craziness that is I mean yeah you
would think you would just be like just
coming up powdered milk with
water mm-hmm just a potted hard it just
looks like with LeBron James claps his
hands before the game that's what it
looks like when he should come when
you're that late like when that guy was
grinding on that chick that's what that
looks like guys on that note uh see geek
do you have you see geek have you ever
used very familiar yes I love seat geek
do you really use it yeah I have I like
it because that you get searches not
only sports and concerts it searches
everything yeah and and a lot of times
you know you go through like these
sketchy third party seats ticket total
is you don't know who you're buying from
you don't trust it and it's not
guaranteed you don't know what's ever
gonna show up yeah I just wish I could
get some kind of discount for my first
time using well I'm glad you asked
that's perfect what a great question
sports van you can use the code
punch-drunk and that gives you $20 off
of your first purchase of any tickets
hey you find a Dodger game Cubs game
some would spend owners you ever Noah
for a hundred two dollars at the orphan
kid me please do not do that punch I
implore all you punch are fans do not
pay $100 don't use our code for that
with Jon Stewart I'd be like maybe 50 if
you want to sit close it's 486 he's
[ __ ] comics just so goddamn greedy
they have no concept that I'm [ __ ]
shitty actor haven't prepared for you're
a work everyday not working on your
stand-up and you can charge 100 bucks
[ __ ] him [ __ ] sure work Kevin Hart have
some respect for your [ __ ] fans
thankfully see geek will mitigate the
cost of these overpriced uh comedy acts
yes they will buy at least $20 if you
haven't used it before and like right
ban said it's a cool thing about it is
you can wherever you go we're about to
all go to Brooklyn all of us we're gonna
be Brooklyn for the skank fest and Amen
let's say we're hanging out in Brooklyn
I'm gonna go see something there BAM
just look it up it'll tell me everything
that's going on in the area that I am
at and it'll search tickets based on how
I want to have it searched look for the
most expensive ticket look for the best
viewed look for the worst viewed look
for the most this kind of they do it all
for you so thank you to a good radio
head July 13th in Brooklyn
Wow is that really true Madison Square
Garden yes holy guacamole how much of
those a billion dollars one hundred
thirty-eight dollars that's not good
that bad for Radiohead Radiohead who
never performs in America they perform
in America about every five years and if
you're my agency CAA if you're
representing Trevor Noah [ __ ] you guys
put you there that's garbage you're
charging $30 less than Radiohead haha
that's true wait what are the better
seats now Trevor Noah went to like for
something if you want to sit close to
Trevor Noah wish hey who wouldn't want
to pay an extra three hundred and fifty
dollars you want to get on I gotta get
close to those jokes which is only 3:30
if you use your code punch-drunk
I'm just saying for Radiohead in
Brooklyn well not you can that's the
most expensive ticket is nine hundred
fifty-three dollars to see radio and
that's like you're pretty much playing
bass for the for the band yeah I think
that's probably a box actually a luxury
box and Madison Square Garden yeah so
yeah you're right Ari that is ridiculous
well I'd rather I'd rather get $20 off
to see radio you can get on the floor
though which is where those Trevor Noah
tickets were in the in the orchestra
$265 so there's a hundred dollars
cheaper I got something better to sit in
the pit than it is for Trevor Noah how
about Saturday November 10th you can see
the best tickets for Burke Chrysler are
three hundred and fifty dollars we're on
SeatGeek
it is I mean a web what his house a new
church that's how he post all those
videos over all the things that he buys
and stuff alright where are you gonna be
so thanks our good friends see [ __ ] use
cut punch-drunk and yes go enjoy a
concert in the summer go enjoy a nice
baseball game go enjoy yourself
about please Dodgers are playing well
all right where you gonna be you got two
dates coming up other than the big skank
fest that we're all at next weekend yeah
because I have to come to LA briefly to
pop I was gonna come in to pay off a
hotdog bet that I guess Tebow ruined a
Nick Youssef ruined I am going to be
doing running my hour are you sure for a
Jew it's a preview of my ed murrow our
July ninth in the belly room tickets are
$8 because it's unfinished what if they
want to sit close what if they want to
sit close 300 also $8 Oh bro that ticket
price goes back up to the normal price
of 20 to 29 50 which is very respectable
yeah and then also I'm doing a
storytelling show in the belly room July
11 so those will both sell out so hurry
up I'm going to Edinboro for the whole
month and then I got my European tour
and Austin in September awesome red bam
what do you got cooking
besides skank fest I go in for Just for
Laughs Montreal of diabetes Li 24 what
are you doing uh kill Tony and I think
maybe comedy if somebody asked me to I
don't know what I'm doing I know I'm
doing kill Tony there but I don't know
about shows yet but I'll be there also
then the Toronto one also hilarities in
Cleveland I'll be there August 1st
let's festival in Fort Wayne oh boy
that's bitter oh yeah comedy off in
Kentucky and xanies and a bunch of [ __ ]
that's quad not TV nice also I will be
at
the dojo this week are for the big for
the viewing party at the Sycamore tavern
for UFC 226 come hang out with a punch
drunk watch the UFC and then after that
we're doing a stand-up show and I
believe that's at 10:00 p.m. in the dojo
right after that $10 cover but if you
want to sit close it is two hundred and
eighty dollars but I'm on that red bands
on that I was taught I was Tripoli's on
that 930 Brodie's on that yeah 930 is
yeah and then we'll start probably
come get some of that 9:30 and then come
early if you want to watch the fights
with all of us of course
skank fest next week I'm at the Comedy
Store Friday Sunday and Monday and guys
big news I got a corporate gig for the
automobile company ow d I'm gonna be a
crash test dummy all of September so
that should be sweet I'm selling my new
line of racist makeup so look for my
Mary Kay Kay Kay Cosmetics booth in the
Valencia mall and then finally I'm doing
a big benefit show for the awareness of
the sexual abuse of space droids so
please come to the hashtag me 2d to show
the sci-fi Network so um see show
Saturday Sam sure I was talking to Kurt
Metzger and he booked both me and Kurt
that's on that yeah you're on that yeah
Brody's on that he they both are we were
both talking about it and he Sam booked
us both on the show without even asking
us he just kind of tweeted it and we
were like oh I guess we're going to do
this yeah you never asked me like I've
even gone back to my texts and well I
see him do that he'll be why do I told
you roadie I think are all Skakel's on
it as well yeah yeah yeah what Brody Lee
sigh it may be Olesya will be there as
well yep that one guy that and Jamie
kill Steen is this the same thing I'm
not sure Mike sit Mike Tully yep that'll
be fun I'll be a lot of fun Mike Mike
totally be fun to watch a UFC and that's
a that's a big card something like this
has never happened before the light
heavyweight champ is fighting the
heavyweights
and what is this Saturday it's Cormier
versus music steep a who's wait no but
whose whose the light heavyweight champ
I'm the heavyweight champ
it is Cormier is the light heavyweight
champ no yes he is Sir
no no that's just no that's not real
what do you mean it's Henry oh you're
saying because because John Jones is I
mean he had to give me a belt up and
then he beat he beat Anthony Johnson for
it he's retired no no who was it did he
fall for it he fought they had to have a
[ __ ] fight for it no he's just a
light heavyweight fighter he's not the
champ who's the champ John Jones or if
he's not fine and no one has the
championship right now but the guy's a
picture with the Bell
no they just just holding it that guy
lost to the title to the [ __ ] champ
twice in a row he's not the champ who's
your buddy who did he fight after that
are we talking about guys it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] more Cormier yeah because they're
fighting for the heavyweight belt not
the light heavyweight belt that's stupid
you don't think this is it a niche
interesting or intriguing fight
whatsoever
yeah a light heavyweight fighter
fighting the heavyweight champ is
intriguing but what Lance why don't they
have anyone else of heavy weight to play
I mean I think he's damn near I mean
what is he five for four in a row I mean
that's damn near clean cleaning in that
division out yeah what's an interesting
fight for him this is an interesting
fight for him and Cormier he's fought at
heavyweight he wrestled it heavyweight
he's fought at heavyweight before this
isn't just like some guy that's good has
to put on at 50 pounds and he's going to
be lumbering his his last win was
volcano's Damir that's we beat after
John Joe
work here's who he helps we lost to John
Jones it was the over then he beat
Anthony Johnson right and Gustafson was
a real fight he went the distance with
Anthony's Anderson Silva being I think
Johnson again where is this guy the
[ __ ] champ and then lost to John
Jones again and then beat again I'm
sorry I'm having trouble reading this
have never heard this guy's name my life
before volcon o's Damir
what was he ranked at that time I'm
talking about yeah sure 15 and two and
one of them is to rumble I mean is to
[ __ ] dent DC yeah he'd lost the
Cormier he lost to manure Manuel that
was a performance of the night for him
or Die he beat I'm sorry Jimmy his
record in the UFC is now 3 & 1
like what are we talking about I mean
maybe maybe I said nothing good the
championship he's just lost and beaten
up Johnson twice who has who else in
that division
should he be fighting I don't know but
he's just clearly not the champ he like
you big silly it's not the champ
it hasn't won a championship he's just
had it handed to him but somebody has to
be and he hasn't done that guy this is
how yes because this is how the ESPN has
the light heavyweight ranked Cormier
John Jones Gustafson Ryan Bader
volcanoes Damir Glover Teixeira Phil
Davis all of those guys he's already
beaten yeah I mean like yeah he's making
the champ he's gonna have to win up like
five six in a row
well what if he wins the heavyweight
title on Saturday he said if he loses
this fight he's retiring if he wins this
night if he was ever been a champ if he
wins this fight he
is tell me who what champion he beat to
become the champion I mean he I don't I
can't think of one
he's just cleared some contenders I mean
ever beat a champ that's how you become
a champion is that beating a champ I
mean yeah but it's also the champ that
he be tested positive for
performance-enhancing drugs Gustavson
went the distance against silver and
then he beat Johnson twice like we'll
see on Saturday so it sounds like you're
excited for 226 I mean it since I'm
excited for that fight that to me is it
kind of fight where it's like you get
excited for the main event you kind of
get that adrenaline rush from me remain
Francis and Gahan is fighting all you
wanna see the heavyweight rankings I can
do it I'm looking up by the way you guys
see that [ __ ] Philippines Australia
brawl what sport basketball yeah yeah
yeah I saw it
yeah I went into the stands everyone's
getting knocked around everybody kept
you know there was like there's like
four or five guys i watch that that's
one of the videos you watch it a bunch
of times there's four or five guys that
are just being held back by coaches and
the yellow jerseys which everyone is are
yellow and they want to get into this
fight so bad and eight they're just
bouncing and they're just all they can
do is yell and Cheer because the coaches
are boasting about YouTube makes me sign
in because it's inappropriate for
someone under 18 yeah that gets annoying
you know I watch people fight if they're
you know really annoys me is the one
where where you have to let's say I want
to look up an old commercial TV
commercial or or I want to watch a movie
trailer which is also a commercial
they'll show you a commercial for me to
watch a commercial I'm already
submitting my will to
up a goddamn advertisement and you're
gonna advertise to me to watch an
advertisement is a good fight oh it's
yeah it's a great humdinger there's a
lot and Tom maker was in this game oh he
did like a like a flying kick yeah the
guy yeah well that's a break out of
flying kicks your first fight yeah
that's a good one the old flying kick
like I detected it there oh he's going
back it goes again oh yeah this goes on
for a hot minute when it's not Americans
because they actually enjoy fighting but
the reward is not a win the reward is
fighting for them well it's not
Americans playing basketball it just
doesn't seem real legitimate yeah oh
[ __ ] chair chair comes flying in did you
see the stupid [ __ ] jerseys that the
uniforms that the Mariners wore this
week they wore like futuristic uniforms
oh god they're terrible and the other
thing is like leave it to like an
Australian the Philippines any of these
soccer playing cards oh boy if you can't
even brush man they really [ __ ] put
on the goddamn John it's like pneumatics
like that car insurance where they act
like she just got yeah just throw him in
a neck brace you know I mean carry him
off like they're dead is that it yeah
that was already toasting up some bagels
and lox and he's always it goes doing
something we always get him it is like
eatin time they award these old
throwback so they did like when ken
griffey was there I guess they're always
gonna be the uniforms of the future cuz
they just wear them and man they are
tears those are ugly they are just
terrible those are ugly so I've been on
this keto diet for five weeks
it's brutal yeah and I haven't cheated
once but I cut off 28:20 carbs 15 to 10
I've been doing I've been going that's
seriously yeah so I've been super no no
it's where you can't eat any sugar or
cards and it's pretty much just like
meat and cheese and [ __ ] but Brendan
Schaub told me that like you should
always take a cheat day and because it
actually resets your your diet kind of
like it'd be shocker system with my
teenagers intimate on your girlfriend
yeah well I do find that you get the
little key if you oh I haven't done it
yet and I was going to ask you what
because like like if you had one cheat
day like I'm gonna go crazy on pizza and
ice cream I think it's the two things
I'm gonna go crazy on maybe some mac and
cheese thrown in there I would miss back
and cheese I would miss pizza yeah the
father's on your diet yeah I would you
know those diets man you just don't eat
a lot of meat what's that mean yeah
pasta and bread pasta bread salad once a
week once a week there's this place that
I love that has like a lobster mac and
cheese I would send Johnny a partner of
it cafe 101 with black chicken yeah yeah
101 with a blackened chicken that's a
bomb good creamy yeah that's a bomb on
anything in a bakery once a week I'll
order up some sort of fancy mac and
cheese are is the answer to your
question weight just drops off right
though I mean once you get hit oh yeah
I've taken my purse with 21 pounds in
five weeks which is crazy but I'm kind
of scared to do this
cheat day because I feel so like I'm
like against it you know like I don't
want to eat ji-won surrounded by idiots
fat he's he's a coffee magnate who's not
interested in anything but himself look
am i and the kid don't listen to those
and don't use their [ __ ] code what's
coming to them don't get yeah they know
what's coming when it comes the way it's
been coming for a long well we just
gotta wait so it arrived it just matters
but we've got a plan we're gonna [ __ ]
it starts with Sam's face
he's gonna go in and there again we say
this before they're just really gonna
give him a hammer and and then that's
when wave to Tay and Rogin come in
speaking of hammering why aren't you in
this basketball game in
I am I am on the coach you should wear
like a shitty suit she wear a shitty 70s
suit I'm the coach yes I've never played
a game of basketball my life so as
Jeremiah playing again no he's out I
still I got that official last night
yeah without his arms broken still yeah
and it's not gonna be healed by the news
and he out and down and Tripoli is in
what was that if you need him he says
Wendy you will need him I can't hear
what he said what you say alright did
you guys see the video of him breaking
his arm yeah it's pretty gnarly he's so
scared of dropping out of hurt yeah and
finally get stuck his arm is broken
immediately yeah yeah yeah and he had
like every single protection known to
man like every knee pad are bad yeah you
almost look like the kid in a Christmas
story you know anyway he just gave me
what his arms that mom wrapped him in
toilet paper and [ __ ] he breaks the
one part of his body that's not covered
yeah why watches but I also want to get
back to 2:26 because I want to do our
pics I want to do our pics well who's
playing then for them who's there who's
your third guy on the team oh we can
keep keep that up I just want to forget
to 2:26
cuz I wanna get our pics in and then I'm
gonna uh my getting on that Oliver Eames
he just fought the other day idea he
just got beat the other day here it is
guys Overeem is done right here you god
this is a video here we go look at him
just drop okay I can do it okay I feel
good he does anyway don't like he
doesn't call it's like a [ __ ] comment
you can't hear when he falls he goes Oh
Frick now he doesn't really say it in
the video okay and bad medicine freaking
do this he does it sounds like a Super
Dave Osborne sketch it's so and I'm
[ __ ]
it's so funny cuz he'll go onstage and
he'll take off his cast before he goes
onstage and then when he gets off stage
people are like oh good job or whatever
like they all like smack on the Army's
yeah I saw him do that he was talking
about that listener I didn't actually
see a set listener but I was talking to
about the game so he's out and who's in
though that's the big question
those talk show he knows there was talk
to Tamara's out it was talk to Sam was
out nao-san was back in and he's back in
and I don't know who's Malcolm Malcolm
I'm guessing he's flying all the way to
New York to play a bass yeah I'm
definitely not playing [ __ ] know I'd
play anything other than dude i'm 5-8
you're taller than josh i'm 5-8 in my
weight I'm not skinny well be
interesting to see who does I'm
interested to see that re let's draw up
those two picks for 226 okay you wanna
start at bottom of the card yeah we'll
start at the well who I want to know who
their head lighting fight is on the
undercard the prelims the top card is
Hall and Kosta Uriah Hall and Uriah Hall
a low cost okay I mean I'm not gonna you
don't talking about to make a bet on
that or anything today at the bottom of
the main card it's Kaleo Roundtree
junior and gokhan Saki I'm gonna go
round tree that looks dangerous just
came off the [ __ ] fighting against
the pipeline
he's [ __ ] ready to fight for the UFC
glory
I like him yeah you I'll take Roundtree
in that okay I'll take the white dude
but he's not white but go ahead
um Francis and Ghana and Derrick Lewis
the black beast Jesus racist gone oh god
oh yeah same that's gonna be them back
that fight could last 30 seconds that
fight will not go three rounds and if it
does it's gonna be a bloodbath there's
such heavy punchers that like anyone can
beat anyone cuz one punch is you're gone
yeah yeah that's what's so impressive
about Steve Hays title run I mean
anybody that's had it's crazy like you
have he's had three title defenses for
title defenses he's the greatest of all
time no one has had more heavyweight
title defenses than he has and it's like
three or four does that say the guy on
the right only weighs 10 more pounds and
the guy that's no well not now that guy
it looks like he has muscle yeah he's a
beast and the right looks like he has a
couple bunny rabbits he pets and sports
band that's been it's bad so in pink I
know we're all going and gonna win this
you got got it man we got Louis Oh Louis
Wow we got a max Holloway and Bryan
Ortega T cities this is the fight that I
like how come he hasn't fighting curved
blades how come is important I was gonna
Volkoff or Derrick Lewis
like that he's got a weird body right
yeah did he currently undergoing
chemotherapy I was watching I was like
he does look like a melting candle they
got a a Brian Ortega has Artie's body in
that photo it looks like he's just been
hiking in Thailand there's a [ __ ]
shirt on his head so he works at
Gamestop Ari's body but none of the
confidence I'm going I'm going Holloway
the Hawaiian nightmare that's not his
nickname but here's Hawaiian right you
gotta go Holloway on this yeah I go
Holloway what Ari or take it looks tough
dog I've been watching them shrinks I
was watching that
what's that UFC not unfiltered the one
they do for the
the fights it's like Jarrod Leno
actually it's a YouTube video it's
almost I got 24/7 for this on the ground
Oh duties like it number one contender
right yeah he's in a one contender yep
okay an event I'll go Holloway and
you'll go take him all right and then
the main event re you're just gonna say
Korea has no chance the way you were
talking about Cormier there's something
about me that feels bad for Cormier like
he's clearly the underdog and what he's
doing
I think he is absolutely he's 35 pounds
lighter well yeah yeah yeah and but [ __ ]
come on 235 it's reported yeah if he can
look at the reach of part of me as ruse
part of me is rooting for DC part of me
is rooting injuries advantage how does
he weigh that picture is very deceiving
is that he looks like a monster compared
to the other guys way taller why does it
say how high they are so so it's he's
fired Daniel Cormier is 511 and the
other guy six four there you go so five
inches in height and but I mean I think
[ __ ] I think steep a wins but I kind of
think for the first time in my life the
first time in my life I'm scared I think
that for the first time in her life I'm
rooting for DC I I don't I don't know
why maybe it's just the [ __ ] you were
talking I mean if he wins this then he's
finally beating a champion and I can I
can see that guy's a champion uh-huh
until then it's like what are we talking
about he's been awarded a belt you got a
[ __ ] sale on Amazon
I don't know I think I'm rooting for
[ __ ] Lefty what Mickelson was like
they're like oh hey we're getting rid of
Tiger Woods so you you're the new best
player he's like no I'm not the best
I've only beating that guy like Twitter
40 times but I mean it's not DC's fault
that John Jones is a [ __ ] no it's not
his fault but also he didn't do it he
didn't beat him if you just kept pulling
out then it's like it's like he didn't
do anything to warrant a championship
not a champion well we'll find out on
Saturday guys here's the deal we gave
you our picks all sports fans as well so
here's what you do go to our good
friends at bet TSI calm and use the code
punch 25 and that gives you 25 free
dollars to gamble with hey say you want
to throw an extra $100 in there guess
what they'll do they'll double that now
you have two hundred and twenty-five
dollars for a hundred dollars you have
two hundred twenty-five dollars to
gamble with throw all of it on our picks
or your picks for UFC 226 bet on the
World Cup bet on baseball right now bet
on anything that you like because they
got it all over there
I imagine World Cup gambling is through
the roof so glad Mexico lost globally
globally
so if soccers you thing or football as
you call it go ahead and get on some of
that and even if you want hey if you're
such if you're so confident about these
damn Lakers and all you Laker fans are
telling me that they're guaranteeing
another championship
take your 25 take your take your 25 free
bucks from us your boys a punch don't
throw it on the Lakers right now winning
the championship and then see if you
don't win money at the end of the year
that's probably okay then you guys Wow
who's your team team oh yeah we're our
team's Oh
the only person alive oops oh I lost the
only person that is still alive I
believe
Eve is we might have a big winner in
England they're playing right now oh I
think it's only Ari and I that are left
who did already have Ari has in Russia
Ari has Russia Russia's Russia's gone
Russia's gone yeah they lost
where did they lose today they lost two
oh no [ __ ] I'm sorry no I thought they
lost the Spain but they didn't lose his
fame no no I apologize I'm wrong cuz
they're poisoning everybody that's why
of course Russia is still magically
alive in the [ __ ] playing soccer in
the Kremlin well dude did you did you
see that thing about how advanced their
cheating was at the Olympics that they
believed they built a building next to
the testing building cut a hole in the
wall yeah and went into the to pull out
the samples there right the logic first
engineered they had these special
hi-tech piss cups that you could they
were almost impossible to open
and the Russians spent months learning
how to open them without destroying the
tamper seal dude they're the Russians
and then replaced all the piss of their
athletes in the and then closed the
whole wall every day I've never met a
Russian that I wasn't scared of so I'm
sure they're cheating I've never met
like an Australian that wasn't nice or
Canadian that wasn't nice never met a
Russian that I wasn't at Montrose is my
order here's what we have nanny
Japan gonzo right bye Felicia bye fish
Lisa had Egypt they're gone
Kareem had Denmark gone yeah sorry
Casper please like Tripoli had Germany
they don't make it out of group toast of
school who to Aaron take America aaron
has Poland gone last in their group just
as I hoped
Johnny had Egypt yeah they've been I I
didn't even wanna I wanted England you
took and Oh Chris had France
yeah there Gonzo's your Johnny books
over there we want you to use your
iPhone because I was rewriting it down
when we were I am Johnny buddy what did
it
two books the two different things well
this one had just this in it so I
brought it because I knew a little black
book Russia re and England teeb the only
two that are left like like you guys had
any sort of thought and enter your
pursued re and I know [ __ ] football
we know that we know the ins and outs of
the forwards and the goal keeps in the
[ __ ] the college [ __ ] and we know all
the lingo sports bands had a goal good
point
III apologize again I mean sports man
what are your thoughts on the World Cup
I don't know I'm more of a mud guy I
don't know you know it's it's it's I I
find it exciting like I I really like
soccer and I really wish it was a little
bit more popular here did you play
soccer growing up yeah yeah the only
sport of legroño is that true yeah at to
what level did you get at soccer like
you played it out three years like maybe
fifth and sixth grade something like
that uh-huh like that and then you're
like no more sports for sports ban no
then I was into skateboarding a Nintendo
I was like [ __ ] this yeah yeah you would
that kid round yeah yeah by the way are
you could buy oversized checks on Amazon
like the big fake checks so when you're
giving that $10,000 to the Children's
Hospital it might be really really
awesome photo opportunity that Burt
won't pay yeah we've raised so if you
want Oh even $5 tops got a go fund
me.com slash evil Burt yeah and we are
really making our way I think within
another couple months we'll have all the
10,000 though you refuse yeah you're up
to six thousand three hundred and forty
seven dollars right now we now explain
this to the people that don't know or
haven't you know haven't followed you on
social media or but he was gonna run a
marathon and in order to get people that
weren't really interested so in order to
get support from people followers on
like Twitter and Instagram
he said that if he finished the marathon
who's gonna give $10,000 of Children's
Hospital right a minute everyone is
super into it Brenna's ISA gave 2,000
razón because of Bert's generosity what
a nice guy
that's a great guy yeah 180 bucks and
and then it came time he won he did it
he finished and then people like hey so
where's this [ __ ] donation happening
and then just wasn't happening and after
a while he finally spoke about it and he
said he just he was never gonna give the
money to the kids he was like nah I
never even I never I never meant to do
that so [ __ ] off all of you
it's just something I said I guess well
yes it was just something said to get
popularity is that it never is that
drunk oh [ __ ] off all of you children
and so I was upset about that Persis my
friend you know I could kind of speak
for your friends hmm at some point I was
like well why why just let him do that I
can't convince I told him he should pay
it it's not cool he refuses he keeps
refusing to pay the bet he'd be promised
and it wasn't just to a person it was to
[ __ ] sick children it's LA Children's
Hospital yeah happy Bob thing they came
here for Christmas probably helps buy
them presents and stuff it's just like
when they're dying all the time right
probably they're dying right now
yeah half of them don't even have feet
and he's buying shoes all the time in
between promisin presents so when they
died how many were present how many do
you think have died since he didn't make
that $10,000 donation god only knows I
wonder how much that poo is he put in
chicken's backyard for a thousand bucks
pop and so then I was like [ __ ] I'll
just raise the money myself
so we all me a bunch of other people we
all sort of banded together so how much
did you say his tickets were rip into I
think the highest ones like over $400
400 and he can't come up with ten yeah
and he begged God for the good-hearted
Ari Shaffir thank you I mean that's yep
that's just 20 that's just and Ari my
favorite part is that not only did you
do $10,000 you did ten thousand nine
hundred sixty-one to cover the fees most
people would not what most people
think of that is that what it is is that
the word that they use for you that's
what I'm looking at this it's all like
$20 $10 $5 so so many people that's how
Obama got elected no Ari has that
changed the way you think about Burt as
a man I don't make this about gender but
as a person for sure I'm disappointed I
mean I'm not joking anymore it's like
it's sort of like I don't know man
okay I was a big Obama supporter and
then I start hearing about these drone
attacks where he's like not even joking
or using hyperbole literally killing
like six-year-old little girls in Yemen
right and then their shell stance was
we're just not gonna talk about it and I
was like well that isn't bringing a
little girl in Yemen back why are we
even in Yemen and your stance is just to
not talk about it you start to lose
faith and the people you would put your
faith that yeah and then it's like oh
people are not infallible in fact
they're not just like [ __ ] up like I
get you to think it was a [ __ ] and
Obama was like hey we messed up we
accidentally bombed a wedding party they
did that many times yeah exactly it was
an oopsie there wasn't even any
terrorists or insurgents there is an
oopsie it imagine a whole wedding party
just killed and we don't care because
they're gonna talk about it and he keeps
doing it and so you start like oh you've
murdered a lot of people not just like
not insurgents like no one even
associated with it so like you stuck
around like that's horrible and that's
sort of the way I feel about bird where
it's like here's a nice guy it's fun to
have around I said my Obama is like
interesting and you want to like support
him but like when you really dig down
you're like there's some darkness there
and it kind of like I try not to face it
because I can't really like be friends
with him if I really think about it too
much
well just do what earth does and dust on
me calm slash evil Burt okay
great cause I'm sorry to bring it down
everybody know it's just for these kids
that are dying every minute yeah yeah
well maybe not every minute maybe don't
even go see a show we know we talked
about those tickets but it's only it's
only 20 tickets the price of 20 to
buying a ticket to go see Burt give
money to the children good idea
ari have you been keeping up on this
Jameis Winston situation at all yeah was
he banned for apparently grabbing what
it sounds like is a uber drivers [ __ ]
and now that that same guy that was
saying [ __ ] him right in the [ __ ] when
he was in college which I always thought
that was funny I didn't think that him
standing commitment now I was like the
big thing every wonder would you get
behind newscasters and they'd be like
[ __ ] her right in the [ __ ] do you
remember that [ __ ] Ari oh yeah yeah when
and then he got in trouble for jumping
on his cafeteria a cafeteria table and
like a dorm room and yelled [ __ ] her
right in the [ __ ] and then everybody
started cheering dude that's just being
a dumb college kid he just happened to
be Jameis Winston who was going pro six
months later I don't think that's a big
deal but this guy has a track record of
doing stupid [ __ ] yeah absolutely yeah a
track like and every time you go you
know what man I just I think Jameis
Winston's misunderstood I just you know
I'm he's just getting a bad rap he's
been accused of sexual assault and rape
in the past someone absolutely did it
Florida State yeah he was absolutely
accused of rape and even when that was
happening and all the details were
coming out you're kind of like yeah I
don't know if oh she sounds like kind of
like a scandalous quote a big athlete
and the NFL reached over and put his
fingers on my crotch at 2:00 a.m. and an
area known for its party scene and
apparently left his hands looking for
crabs and apparently left his hand there
and then she says what's up with that
and then he pulls his hand away
and I believe it's when they were maybe
even in a drive-through or at a
restaurant the eighties the 86 year old
uber driver said that they were in a
drive-through what do you think the
drivers playing this right there don't
you go to this this guy's
representatives like quietly and say hey
man I could really cause you some
trouble
let's just get some cash on the slope I
think legally that's like blackmail yeah
but like your attorney and say hey man
we got a beat yeah you do it legally
like you're gonna sue them threatened to
sue but just keep it out of court you
know have their attorney no no no
because I was talking to the settlement
you nobody ever finds out about it I was
talking to a Kevin Black my buddy Kevin
Black who you know his job has always
been like he brokers sex tapes like
celebrity sex tapes oh that guy and
somebody came to him with a famous
athlete recently and these prostitutes
or whatever they you know call girl you
know the people you get the high-end
escort type of lady still it's still
prostitution yeah so this guy and and
they realize when they get to his house
that he's somebody famous and then they
get a photograph of his driver's license
smooth move there so they know who he is
and then they get like photos of him in
compromising situations and then they
wanted to release this sex tape and but
they had gone to his representation or
whatever and is that hey we went X
amount of money or we're gonna release
this that is what I'm talking about and
so we can yes Daily Mail mm-hmm so then
the yeah it's Oscar De La Hoya's house
but if only I only say that because it's
apparently all over the internet as well
but and then they go to our friend and
said hey you want to want you to sell
the sex tape and he goes okay sure dan
sent it to me and they send it to
some of this and he goes have you talked
to him they go yeah and he goes oh boy
he goes did you ask him for money and
they're like yeah we asked him for like
a million dollars or something like that
he goes there's nothing I can do because
you but a black male that's like a
federal offense and I guess like they
try to get really you know they try to
do this this is not him wearing like the
the lazy eye he's a freak but apparently
he had kitchen utensils in his ass yeah
and then why do people sit in the front
of ubers do you guys do that is that a
thing I get carsick so that's in the
front I don't and it almost makes me
know I sit in the back and Stroke it and
everything I don't go that far but I do
sit in the back I'm like that's on them
they don't want me up there but if it's
empty it's like yes sure can you're
right I think if I was an uber driver I
want people to sit in the back no you do
not with me like I just want to be
that's my office
yeah front seats my office yeah if I was
uber driver great yeah III I think it's
I think it's rude to sit in the front
seat well it just makes me feel makes me
feel like uncomfortable are you have you
changed your stance on airplanes about
putting the seat back a little use less
ever don't put your seat back on
somebody there's less room than ever now
they keep taking away room yeah but you
do if everybody puts their seat back
it's even and even that right let me
explain to you how you can okay okay
here's my look see my legs yeah okay now
watch what happens when I lean back see
them yeah but that's because you don't
have a support on your back right now
okay this is this is this is not
scientific or that's not scientific
listen when you leave your seat back
it's only your upper part moves back
they haven't gained worst room you lean
back from your waist up your legs stay
the same it's not a question of that
there's one airline I saw dragon air in
in Asia and instead of leaning your seat
back you just push yourself forward so
it goes kind of like that and guess what
nobody [ __ ] does it cuz you're just
taking away your own legroom you know
it's rude as [ __ ] you all know it's
weirdest [ __ ] there's somebody there and
anyone who's like it's my see I can do
whatever I want it's like all right you
live in an apartment building and see
what happens somebody's banging on your
[ __ ] roof all night so you don't
ideal you don't do it you don't know you
never sitting in the chair and go you
know what my back is killing me I need
to put a tap back a little oh yeah my
back is killing me sitting down is too
hard and this seats are so uncomfortable
after like two hours I'm just like
I mean it's uncomfortable no matter what
yeah I'm not sure I agree apparently
apparently a lot of people do think
that's forty one percent of people think
that it's rude to recline your seat
during a flight
yeah re re used to I don't know if he
still does is he's useless if you lean
in front of him he starts kicking seats
from Qatar may be so hot I know I think
with the VC and it was like somebody
leave back and there's just no room so
I'm nice my my leg is up and it's on
there and she's like why do you keep
hitting on my I can't my legs can't go
anywhere unless they laid me like wide
wide open and she was like what do you
mean manspreading so I'm like I wish
with you like I won't lean back on you
if you want to sit behind me you can you
can do that and then she was like no I
have a seat open next to me I'm like
alright then maybe I don't know but I
can't like show me where this room
there's no room right where I can put my
legs yeah you're tall what do you like
6:00 to 6:30
there's definitely airlines that are
getting worse my legs are like what an
inch and a half longer than someone
who's 511 these are according to a
survey that's published at 538 the
rudest things you can do on an airplane
the first is knowingly bring unruly
children on an airplane that's the worst
course wake someone up to go for a
walk so you should go for a walk Rick
recline your seat is third wake someone
up to use the bathroom as fourth bring a
baby on a plane ask to switch seats for
a friend that is annoying what someone's
like I hate when this might bring whoo
yeah but if it's putting you in the
middle
[ __ ] that I hate when somebody brings in
like horrible smelling food you know
like how about barefoot how about the
people that just take their shoes
completely off and put their [ __ ]
feet right Romney that's being really
chatty like if you're talking to a
stranger you know and they don't want to
talk that's rude that's the next one and
move to an unsold seat so if there's an
empty seat you move there and [ __ ] in
my El Tovar by moving there that's
considered the also rude and then asked
to switch seats for family so that's the
list
so yeah are yours is like third recliner
see I had no idea a lot of them are not
Robbie's was this list made before 9/11
I'm sitting by the window somebody's
sleeping I will hold it in until I am
ready to burst
no I they need to can't take any more
than I'm like I'm so [ __ ] can't a try
for an hour
I can't I'm gonna explode I'm sorry I'll
try to get over them without them no
like waking up but like well I just
stare at them for like 38 minutes so
they open up you a window guy what's
your preference I try to get the aisle
hundred-percent window yeah me too
and what's up with them airplane pillows
like has anyone ever bought one of those
I was like this is the most comfortable
this makes space saw they make no sense
it's better if you turn around actually
because then you can kind of oh I have
mine like in a ball next like in the
window like I should just bring a pillow
I don't never see why you worthless
it makes nothing emotional yeah I never
use those things I'm gonna sleep and I
never use the ones that they give you
which is just like a shitty little
[ __ ] it look like a clutch purse or
something what the [ __ ] is this gonna do
it looks like a [ __ ] giant [ __ ]
maxi pad for an old lady
that's a pillow you don't you know do we
have a big J update re we have I
actually talked to Chris
see and she said he has received some
dick pics already nice I did I did yeah
after you suggest about that yeah you're
thinking behind that was that he wanted
to get calls all day long not when he's
just yeah if it's three I'm just gonna
have us phone off and so that it won't
really
he'll just wake up to messages I like
the idea of it like you'll get called
all the time but it you can just turn
your phone on mute yeah yeah yeah I mean
really as long as he gets messages he
gets message he also can get messages at
his account and I've seen those and he's
actually getting a lot of compliments
like a lot of like hey cutie I love
rocker guys yeah we should we should go
through his comments too when we do do
it the only we do the pot at skank fest
well happens right no players messages
but we'll go through and read his
account as well
I hope my yeah it's a really give them
don't worry now the people that message
him I do give them his cell phone
network so that they can contact him so
that's perfect yeah that's so now you
are pretty much just like this is like
Cyrano de Bergerac hitting you up on his
account in here and I'm like sure I'd
love this like yeah that and I do yeah
I'd love to suck your dick call me
anytime please I can't stress that
enough I found that the older guys give
a lot better later more likely to
respond to soive what do you mean
targeted because they're more desperate
because they have less options yeah
what's older like 60 plus yeah he's
gonna get himself a gummy bear oh it's
like it doesn't get hard no that's when
just like you get your dick sucked by
someone with no teeth oh okay
and only way you can get a gummy bear is
a bear okay old person drug addict or a
baby and two hours bring it back because
who wants a dick sucked by a drug addict
right but yeah that's a gummy bear so
he's gonna get one of those he's gonna
pull his teeth out and then can you I
mean if you think about it and excluding
babies the gums Joe Villages gums that's
gotta feel pretty good on it
the way bad thing about a blow jobs
teeth the scratching us take him out and
now you guys self just gonna comes hey
out take out remember
trunk Katie was at the comedy store the
other day I saw it was her birthday so
she was an extra drunk and it was also
Ritchie's girl's 15-year wedding
anniversary they're out and they're good
friends Katie wasted I walk in with my
girlfriend we sit down my girlfriends
you know never met or anything oh and
Katie comes up guys
hey you know they give a good blow job
you gotta use the spit from the back of
your throat you just gag it and then it
just starts getting want and tell my
girlfriend that girl's crazy
remember drunk Katie re she does all the
time yeah all the time usually after 50
Irish car bombs and she's usually
looking for some boss and athletes to
[ __ ] L'Arche did you ever [ __ ] her know
that alright yeah yeah I was I she liked
to peep up Tanner than I but I there was
a definite window where I would have
loved to yeah you she's not bad back in
the day oh dude she was [ __ ] her
body's incredible and especially when
you factor in all like you know as much
as she does to it mm-hm
you know drinking him whatnot like she
still looks pretty goddamn great how
does somebody drink that much every
single it's a boss those Bostonians can
put it down son
people from Boston people from Chicago
Irish people Canadians Australians those
are all people they can just they're
just can't stop they just go and it can
just keep they're indestructible when
they drink people in Boston you know you
go to when you walk to a Cubs game from
like you're like like if you're on the
north side and you would walk because
you don't want to pay to park every like
two blocks you would stop at a bar and
do like a boilermaker like a shot and a
beer and then you walk four more blocks
and then putt light pop in here by the
time you get to the stadium those
got four beers and four shots in him I
can't even follow sports when I'm even a
little buzzed it's movies and [ __ ] like
that doesn't do anything doesn't help I
mean in the 90s you didn't go to the
Cubs game to follow the sport that's a
good point
you went there to drink and hit on girls
and then drink after the game
what are they thinking about saying it
like Sammy Sosa is he totally like
persona non grata there is he [ __ ]
[ __ ] he cheated no no like still love
yeah I mean they love all white people
dude he is white now to you it's almost
like marry yes what Michael Jackson has
right or Hattie Lagos yeah yeah and if
they could recognize him if you look at
the difference in how he but sober like
how he used to look wow that one go to
the middle the top one above it like
look yeah look at him I mean he looks
like a look at that top one in the
middle now that the top left another one
over to the left we had yeah that's
crazy so he didn't have makeup on before
he's just getting it worse on his face
that's just no makeup well in think
about now he's way into the Sun way less
now but he got pale isn't that weird
yeah he used to be in the Sun all the
time he was black yeah yeah maybe maybe
you just had a tan yeah I don't know
it's a weird looking at when you see
like what it is it's like you see who he
is like no dude that's pretty pale look
at this one like that I mean he looks
like a [ __ ] Cuban drug lord on the
right that is not a tan there's
something going on hey look how young he
is over there on the left though that's
when everybody was everybody was
cheating in baseball they're like you
know what everything goes they couldn't
load those drugs up fast enough yeah
they were like it was like with the pry
yeah yeah pride it was like how pride
was weird his lips stayed the same color
he looks like that's it he lives the
exact same color the rest of us can all
change look at that the lips are still I
mean I can't really tell a difference oh
the one on the left is a little lighter
I guess it could also be just Fattah
you know like it could be like that
camera was brighter than the other
camera but look dude that him that
changes in a year look at that it's May
2009 November 2009 he went from like
brown to beige maybe he's like 5 months
he went he lost all those shades
yeah that's nuts
shaking a brown almost made it
what's what's the sitch back there it's
been a while since we got an update on
the old a-hole
all right I need to release like a
20-year anniversary master mastered for
cave directors guy what you see that on
many TV you know this whole part was an
improv
well I think that worst part is is when
me and Eddie are just hanging out and
then he [ __ ] throws his toilet paper
I mean that's just disgust it's like he
did that during the [ __ ] bleaching
yeah I remember uploaded the live like
bacon well they could to show
decapitation so they can show Ahri's
[ __ ] yeah zero desire to see that's
all we had to do with the [ __ ]
bleaching it's on pornhub is that some
gay guys are really digging it your old
man [ __ ] that's a man this is man purse
no man [ __ ] are they cut good Ari but
he sucks about genres huh yeah
to god but honestly I do wanted to die
for a long time yeah he's been in pain
forever
oh why this was crazy back summers ago
once Norton had a HBO like stand-up show
yeah and we were doing it we're staying
in this thing in New York and we're
driving to Manhattan oh no we're staying
New Jersey we're filming in New Jersey
we drove into Manhattan so do run
throughs and so Rachel rush now a
high-powered agent at CAA
was driving and she was that the
headhunter that and she was driving us
and we're all in a band and we're all
[ __ ] poking her and throwing [ __ ] at
her and she's on the highway there was
meat stick Nick's arouse on the way back
of his conversion van Louis Katz Jeff
Jeff Keith a bunch of guys were there
and she was having trouble driving and
she was like guy stopping stopping we
can't [ __ ] punch an ER and [ __ ] and
then she goes guys stop it doesn't lick
was there SH because do you guys want to
die and then just rouse very quietly
next to me just goes yes
sorry sorry yeah man he was just doing a
lot of pain for a lot a long time he had
a lot and multiple multiple surgeries
and but he was a funny [ __ ] guy he
was a nice guy he was fun to drink with
he was fun to do gigs with he was very
cynical and quick last time I talked to
him was right after he got his legs
fixed by me to Russell or Doug's
it paid for it and I remember he
actually seemed happy about it like he's
like oh I feel great
yeah but that but at that you know that
was short-lived yeah and then I was in a
coma for a couple days I guess and then
just passed away so you know anybody
feel free to look up Sean rouse to stand
up
we've been post some stuff about it all
things comedies to put some links up but
you know he's one of those comics did a
lot of people probably never heard of
real good friends with Stan home Stan
opposed we always take him on the road
and you know just sucks win when you
lose a buddy and when you lose somebody
that's funny he was a real cool guy and
I'm glad he's no longer in pain yeah you
know that's for a long time that's one
of those ones we like man that sucks but
you know what
you know it's like when my uncle died of
Lou Gehrig's disease I was like
I miss him but [ __ ] did it's serious
glad to not see him suffering all the
[ __ ] hopefully when they buried him
they're like those death for a while so
I was fine with that one but I get what
you're saying
the other ones hopefully when they
buried him they didn't like fold him in
like meat you know like hopefully they
laid him out like nice and comfortably
that [ __ ] doesn't matter burn me man
I've learned me before I'm dead burning
but what if they figure out how to like
yeah i'vei've you for watching west
rotor yeah they're gonna be able to take
your bones out and reprogram you and
throw you back into the same block once
I'm gonna go wherever I'm supposed to go
straight down I told of like for a while
the best way I was like if I was gonna
kill myself here's what I want to do 400
foot Tower right 400 foot tower like 40
stories chained me up at the top of that
light me on fire let me burn for a while
then push me off that building let me
fall 40 stories into a [ __ ] river and
then I drowned that's combining all of
the ones that everybody's afraid of oh
there's some sharks in here too
but then I thought the other way that
would be a good way if you're gonna kill
yourself is the opposite just zip
yourself in a body bag and just wait
this you're eventually gonna die in that
thing first you're gonna run out of cell
service that's gonna suck you start
pissing yourself and [ __ ] yourself
yeah it's gonna be a lot of piss and
[ __ ] in there for a while you're right
you might drown I don't think it'd be
that much piss re as your parents ever
told you anything about your not being
able to be buried in a Jewish cemetery
are they upset with you with the tattoo
is that in Jewish law there is no such
thing as a Jewish cemetery the
commandments are if someone dies you
have to bury them and there's other
commandment is if you're a Cohen if
you're part of the priests tribe you
cannot walk into a cemetery
there's no Jewish cemetery non Jewish
cemetery you have to bury people that's
it
so it's just an old house wives tale so
I get their kids their sons not to get
tattoos but it's that's not a real thing
that's interesting that's really uh
because I hear that [ __ ] all the time
like the Jewish cemeteries or come to
comes from a place in America and
England Western society which Jews had
so much money they could afford to have
buried together Pacific burial areas but
did those burial areas have a Jewish
country club did those areas tore up
do those burial areas have rules though
all right the the the ones that are run
by Jews there are rules
yeah it's not saying that but they have
like you can have a tattoo like is that
one of the rules mark up your body but
the law is also that same law isn't it I
think in the same sense the next sense
you also not only get a bull cut hair
cut
well that's a good rule like copying
another race so it's like we trace which
races act go ahead and say it
I a better driver I guess I guess that
makes sense because like how many Jewish
people had their numbers and then they
you know what I mean like the Nazi
number right here we just add three 1722
to it that's his lottery numbers he
always plays all right what do you think
about we haven't talked to in a while
this Kellen Winslow jr. [ __ ] have you
heard this you know who he is
have you heard all the trouble that he's
in what was it okay you're gonna love
this he is now in jail waiting trial and
everything for multiple kidnappings for
sodomy 'he's rapings and robberies
kidnappings rapings and robberies of
elderly women some in there seven I'll
give you the rundown here the complaint
includes the following allegation
the rape just gotta just add just took
over the entire [ __ ] screen hold on a
second
okay forced oral copulation of a 54 year
old in March kidnap rape and sodomy of a
59 year old in May indecent exposure in
May burglary with the intent to rape a
71 year old woman in June and burglary
with the intent to rape an 86 year old
woman also in June big month for
Kellerman's Oh 86 years old
this guy likes gummy bears what is this
guy doing Ari that's crazy it's [ __ ]
crazy
he's a player professional sports
athlete and it all happened in San Diego
where he grew up also where his dad was
like a superstar tight end for the
charges trooper said what mrs. dad be
thinking that's what I'm saying his dad
must be like would you have besmirched
my name so we could have bought you a
prostitute you didn't have to break into
somebody gonna bought you an old
prostitute we could have bought you like
a person from Thailand literally a human
I mean Jesus I it's good it's weird to
me too I mean he probably could just get
women that age right easily oh he's
younger than me he's got to be in his
30s definitely he's he was I was out of
college when he was playing college ball
he's 34 yeah he's 34 Wow so that's what
that's a rape in 81 year old women 52
two-year-old age difference between him
and the 86 year old that's insane Jesus
criminy I mean it's not that there he
needs to be like they can't outrun him
what is that what the protoid any can
outrun this and like a mother issue what
is that that you would be that into ello
women who fetish couldn't be in the
diapers yeah yeah like can you imagine
being attracted to women that old like
because I mean re re grossed out by 35
year old earlier and older the women
kept getting other when life is a 60
they ever looked at like old old old old
people porns like where the woman
doesn't even know who she is and there
where are you watching old people porn
porn hubs and the like this was pornhub
like I've seen that a few times we're
like the ladies like 90 years old she
doesn't know who she is and they're all
from behind and know where to go what
are you watching yeah it's like blue
iris stuff but I mean she's like can
this at consensual she's acting like
that or she signed some paper before
that's horrible
it's pretty weird to watch once you feel
guilty watching once your minds gone
that does it really even count I mean
I'm excited for this [ __ ] a [ __ ]
great retirement home [ __ ] [ __ ] fast
coming down the pipes that's not that
far away for us yeah it's like 30 years
20 years next week I believe we're gonna
have our you're in studio next week
correct yeah that'll be good we'll see
who our guest but yeah but I know your
team will be calling in Josh Martin and
Tony will be calling in to talk a little
[ __ ]
but this basketball thing is playing - I
can tell no I really don't know yeah I
gave - he doesn't know now they keep on
talking about - and I'm just like you
know what it's probably good what names
of year it's probably gonna be like I'm
gonna be like you know what I'm gonna
stay in my hotel room and have fun guys
let me sleep it's gonna be it's a five
o'clock Friday that's what we saw right
that's when the game is 5 p.m. i p.m.
really you good with that Ari 5 o'clock
Friday I don't know if we're good I
don't even if we fly in and well that
was the big problem yeah they have a lot
of people who weren't flying into like
4:30 yeah I think that's when our flight
is is like that game it's 5 o'clock
Friday when do you fly when do you fly
in Ari Thursday night oh eye out Friday
morning
we were gonna do that and they tell us
not to and now we really should have
because you're gonna be going straight
from the [ __ ] airplane to the
basketball game I'm ready I'm ready
right now I'm yeah but that's fine and
hold on just real quick and I'll tell
you when our podcast is me so hard and
then we're doing stand-up - right I was
in a stand-up show around I have one in
a stand-up show
I don't know honky-tonks podcast it's 3
p.m. Saturday mm-hmm the late afternoon
slot that's fine no we but are we doing
is there standard spots - I think
everybody's got yeah it's it you'll have
to look at the final schedule mmm
thank you I mean they probably have you
booked on other shows - yeah all the
stand-ups I think I book - um I've
gotten any of those
I haven't booked I should go - archfield
I got sliced skank fast for my skating
class news yeah and also let me know
your festival when I'm doing stand-up he
holds his Twitter epëus weirdest way
ever
this is guys never seen anyone do that
before before this gets way worse that's
been punch honks what are ya oh god damn
it up guys thanks no he's not liking it
don't like it please all right don't
like it please like it like it the
creepiest folding of toilet paper ever
it's like serial killer [ __ ] guys thanks
for didn't know he did it
no he didn't know he did it oh my god oh
my god oh my god what's wrong with you
you're adult an adult if it's your old
man guys as always go to all comedy
t-shirts calm and get yourself tree on
Strunk shirt and subscribe to put you
we're gonna have a ton of great ship
from skank fest from patreon like travel
vlogs and behind the scenes basketball
whatever yeah okay like that so please
subscribe to patreon and and you can
hear us talk about last week on the this
week's episode what all the [ __ ] we talk
about all of that and be nice to Sam
guys be nice to Sam on Twitter
especially this is passionate why use
right now use the support from the past
yeah it's all games to make fun of
people and then sometimes I think fans
don't realize it like yeah we bust balls
but we really know each other so you go
into it not like you can't take a
ballbusting it's like no no I can take a
ballbusting from a guy who I know yeah
he's a good friend of mine not from a
guy you have no positives or negative
with so sometimes the fans [ __ ] on you
and I think it's funny on my like
Instagram accounts what everyone like
makes fun of me out it's okay but
sometimes it gets the point we're like
the [ __ ] is this and it's not just you
it's 880 other people so there's times
when you need some positive
reinforcement it wouldn't be the worst
time to [ __ ] let's stand though a
couple things either you do like about
them oh sure yeah and he's awesome or
she you know he's more sensitive than we
are yeah so like you get [ __ ] on I've
never seen anything like you getting
[ __ ] on you get [ __ ] on a lot yeah I'm
the number one shiny new poster you
posted something and tag me in it and it
was just non-stop you getting [ __ ] on so
I don't know how you guys deal yeah I'm
horrible yeah so be nice is Sam you've
dumb Fox
you're gonna you're only hurting the
show do you have stained underwear re
from the blood how much blood is that
are you do you have stained underwear
leave I looked over most of it it's
gonna keep flowing now now I gotta plug
yeah I just got make a man poem blood
doesn't wash out there right you get
stains no nobody's gonna play a little
bit
oh you shot that's the move yeah okay
hey Ari I found out if you put a little
dab of Vaseline on the hemorrhoid it
starts cutting it clots itself if you
put a little Vaseline on like the tip of
the hemorrhoid it clots so you don't
have to use like toilet paper
anything like that yeah cool cool yeah
thank you so much man thank you Aaron
take you Jonny thank you guys
Ari's be nice to Sam suck it